did you guys see the trailer for
spider-man 2 like the new spider-man
game here's the funny thing i was under
the impression i don't know why i
thought this but i felt like spider-man
miles morales was basically spider-man
2. and then like at the playstation
announcement by the whole playstation
event they're like spider-man 2 is gonna
have miles morales and spider-man facing
off against venom and i was like what
and then i started thinking i was like
yeah i guess it wasn't really called
spider-man 2. i guess it was just
spider-man miles morales that's awesome
right so i'm really excited about that
game like i am so hyped about that game
so having said that we are continuing on
with the amazing spider-man dance slots
run we're finally finishing this after
like two years
and this is the osborne identity right
this is the return of norman osborne now
here's the funny thing about this is
this whole thing picks up basically with
like a big you know drug run a big drug
trade that's taking place here right now
one of the things to keep in mind this
is one of the things to remember is that
part of the reason why spider-man is
here in del vadia is that while it is a
foreign country parker industries is
basically kind of a global initiative so
while peter parker is still kind of the
friendly neighborhood spider-man he
still deals with threats that are
credible that have impacts on new york
city and america itself when things go
on abroad the other reason for why he's
here is he's hunting norman osborne now
we'll get to that here in a second but
the important thing is while they're
there there's two things happening at
the same time the first is that you
basically have spider-man and you have
bobby morris right like mockingbird a
lot of you guys know her she's a shield
agent because again parker industries
especially spider-man himself kind of
has a loose affiliation with shield in
the sense like they're kind of working
together not all the time but him and
mockingbird kind of have a thing going
on and we'll actually see where that
leads to as we cover continue to cover
dan slot stories but uh but in this
instance you've got them who are
basically here trying to hunt norman
osborne at the same time dealing with
this big drug trade because this is
where this road has basically led them
and then you've also got somebody else
here and the funny thing is that while
there are like armed guards that are
standing outside this drug den where
things are going down that this person
who's basically cloaked ends up taking
these guys out now here's the important
thing about this the spider tracker
software the spider bots of peter parker
as they were developed by dr octopus
during the superior spider-man storyline
are highly capable and they can detect
pretty much anybody anywhere within a
general vicinity regardless of how well
they're hidden this particular person
knows how to overcome that stuff which
means it tells us right off the bat this
particular person is very adept when it
comes to using different forms of tech
and so ultimately because of the fact
that these guards are taken out by this
invisible person that there is a little
bit of indication as far as mockingbird
in them go that like hey like was there
somebody there like i thought this whole
area was clear and the response of peter
is no the bots say the area is clear the
whole place is clear there's nobody
there right so again able to overcome
peter's abilities now the other part
about this is that you've got nick fury
who's kind of watching things at least
from the direction of where shield is
coming from and he's also kind of
feeding peter parker information right
because as capable as bobby morris is as
a shield agent at the end of the day
having nick fury is kind of the eye in
the sky really helps things out
immensely right because nick fury is
highly capable i mean he is the director
of shield right so he has that position
for a reason now the question as to how
it is they managed to find norman
osborne why they're hunting norman
osborne and what's going on with this
character let's go ahead and answer this
so the idea is that if you guys recall
in our last video where we did the clone
conspiracy and that kingpin gave peter
parker information that would lead him
to the location of the jackal the
kingpin's initial response is that in
doing this you're gonna owe me a favor
and the response of peter was no the
jackal basically initiated a personal
assault on you by resurrecting your dead
wife and presenting her to you as what
he thought was a peace offering you took
that as a high level of offense so you
want the jackal destroyed probably more
than i do so i'm gonna take this
information i'm gonna bring down the
jackal but you kingpin are gonna owe me
a favor and ultimately kingpin's a man
of his word that's one of the things to
understand kingpin's brutal right
kingpin wilson fisk is brutal he's
intense he will kill whoever he needs to
kill i mean this guy has almost no
morality whatsoever when it comes to
dealing with anybody who is a threat to
his empire however he is an honorable
man and i know those two things seem to
run in contradiction with each other how
can you be amoral and be honorable at
the same time it's just kind of the
nature of kingpin but he is an honorable
guy when he makes a promise to you he
will keep it it doesn't mean he won't
kill you after but he will keep it
and so he made this promise to peter
fine i will owe you a favor and so what
he does is he presents him with
information that will say this will not
give you the exact location but it will
get you on the trail to norman osborne
now the reason why this is so important
is because at the end of superior
spider-man the superior spider-man
basically cured norman osborne of his
green goblin persona right wipe the
slate clean it was a way for dan slot to
kind of get rid of all that stuff and
then just sort of start over kind of
write the story in a in a different
direction which worked it was really
really cool but in effect norman osborne
was no longer bound by the insanity that
came with the green goblin persona the
belief of superior spider-man was that
with that being done norman osborne
would no longer be a credible threat the
funny thing is he's actually more
dangerous now than he was when he was
the green goblin and so the crazy thing
is that getting on the trail they
ultimately end up realizing yep this is
norman osborne's location when they come
across the goblin army now the goblin
army was in effect the army of norman
osborn right i mean it makes sense it
was one of these things that that marvel
was toying with at the time where it was
kind of like like what if green goblin
had his own variation of like the joker
serum right and that instead of making
people crazy and they basically laugh
themselves to death they end up becoming
his henchmen right what if it worked
that way that was the whole thing about
the the goblin serum right the goblin
formula if you want to call it that but
at the end of the day of course finding
these guys here they're kind of like yep
we're in the right spot right we're in
the right location now ultimately this
invisible person is basically planting
charges
[Music]
outside of what is in effect this kind
of base of operations for the goblin
army and when a couple of unsuspecting
people right who just kind of wander
over right curiosity kill the cat
they're kind of curious about what's
going on when they walk over and they're
like what in the world is this and then
one of them is like hey go grab that
thing and bring it over to me uh this
person is like no nobody touched these
things right and even goes so far as to
shoot in the air to distract anybody
right to get everybody just kind of
running away and so picking back up with
spider-man mockingbird and all these
guys they end up coming across the guy
who's basically kind of running the show
here and i'm i hope i'm getting this
pronounced correctly i believe i am el
faso i think it's how you pronounce this
so this guy is basically the one who's
running the show here and just kind of
shooting everything up right just kind
of going nuts apparently it stands for
the warthog i guess whatever the case is
this guy is kind of the the main boss in
this part of the world or this part of
the country and so essentially while
this whole big battle is going on
spider-man looks at this guy and
immediately believes he's norman osborne
right he's like all all arrows point to
the fact that this guy is osborne we'll
talk about what those arrows are here in
a second but before anybody can really
do anything this invisible person
topside basically detonates these
charges and blows up the entire area and
so this essentially leads to uh the
warthog if you want to call him that
basically disappearing right just
bailing getting out as fast as he
possibly can spider-man and mockingbird
have to bail as well but spider-man
chases after this guy right he
immediately goes after who he thinks is
osborne and manages to like literally
chase him down right manages to track
this guy down and then capture him right
now the biggest issue about this is
while spider-man is convinced this guy
is osborne when they wash out to the
sewer drain they end up out in the in
the muck right in the the garbage pit
he's like both of you are crazy i am not
norman osborn and then once you switch
over to shield hq it's confirmed right
this guy's fingerprints his voice his
face he's not norman osborne right none
of this really makes sense and so it
almost kind of looks like peter parker
is basically losing his mind at that
point you switch over to the countess of
delvaria and you find out that norman
osborne is alive and norman osborne
looks like this guy and the reason why
and this is actually a genius maneuver
what norman osborne has been doing to
both discredit spider-man as well as
throw him off his trail is osborne has
actually been having facial
reconstructive surgery to replace his
face with criminals from the criminal
underworld across the world itself and
just with people in general it's what
keeps spider-man from being aware of the
fact that he's alive or being able to
tangibly locate norman osborn and it's
one of the smartest things that a person
could have possibly done because you got
to think if parker industries is a
global industry right they've got all
kinds of tech and resources at their
disposal you have to assume facial
recognition has to be one of those vocal
recognition has to be one of those right
all that has to kind of fit in and that
while norman osborne still maintains the
same voice walking around with a
different face and just not really
saying anything to anybody or if he does
that he can kind of talk low enough or
talk in a place where any kind of parker
vocal recognition wouldn't pick him up
it is a little uh kind of conspiracy
theory
but when you're a major villain trying
to escape a major superhero it kind of
makes sense that you would go to those
lengths and so in the aftermath of this
you end up learning that what peter
parker's been doing has actually been
using parker industries different you
know meetings or different charitable
events and things like that hosting them
in different locations based on where
the perceived location of norman osborne
is and then using that as a means to
investigate and it kind of makes sense i
mean at the same time though it's also
kind of a terrible idea because if every
time spider-man shows up a parker
industries charity event happens to be
going on at the same time somebody
somewhere is gonna put two and two
together and say why is it that
spider-man's always in the same location
where there is a parker industries
charity event this dog don't bark man
right somebody is going to have enough
sense to know what's going on and so at
the end of the day they all end up kind
of going through it right they're
heading to hong kong essentially but
before they do peter parker kind of
deviates for a second ends up going to
hang out with aunt may a lot of that's
just because of dan slot kind of telling
the story involving the extended you
know cast members of the the spider-man
uh comics themselves which it is kind of
cool right seeing peter parker hang out
with aunt may he hasn't really seen her
for a little while harry osborne of
course and betty brant have a kid those
of you guys who don't know who betty
brant is she was the first girlfriend of
peter parker his first real true love
was gwen stacy right after that it was
mary jane watson but ultimately he kind
of brings him all along he's like hey
everybody let's go
let's all go to hong kong right one
because of the fact aunt may is
basically in charge of like the uncle
ben charity foundation right harry
osborne has his role in parker
industries so it's is it being a kind of
big huge charity event they all kind of
need to be there anyway but hey who's
never looking for a good excuse to go to
hong kong and just hang out i'd go there
for the food not even gonna lie right
the the food would be like my main
motivation for going to hong kong i love
chinese food but having said that um
once they get there of course they start
going through going through and
investigating kind of looking through
everything so on and so forth their
trail kind of again leads them on this
path of finding out we're at least sort
of hopefully locating where they believe
norman osborne is the problem with this
is that again norman osborne seems to
kind of be using this identity of el
faso quero now again the big issue with
this is that peter parker and them
believe that norman osborne is this guy
which temporarily he is they don't know
that norman osborne is using facial
reconstructive surgery and so in their
mind there have been five sightings of
this guy across the world and they're
basically hunting all of them down
what's keeping norman osborne ahead of
peter parker is that by the time they
get to the point where they realize that
this el faso quiero is just an identity
used by norman osborne he's already on
to his second third fourth identity so
they'll always be three four five steps
behind him in terms of trying to track
him down again that's the genius of all
this that's what makes norman osborne so
incredibly good here and so ultimately
once they end up grabbing one of these
henchmen they find some you know some
pumpkin bombs they're like okay
basically everything here right these
goblin gliders and all this stuff this
all screams of of norman osborn right so
tell me where this guy is at and
ultimately he's not initially dumping
the information and then then things
start to get kind of heavy-handed right
like mockingbird is kind of like hey i
mean look we could kill you you know i
mean just no you know we could kill you
right and nobody would know i mean
nobody's nobody would know that you're
dead right you'd just be at the bottom
of the water somewhere or maybe we just
put you in the cement wall and cover it
up obviously they're not gonna do that
but when you're a guy when you're a
henchman in the criminal underworld hell
anything's possible and people that you
thought were good guys turn out to be
bad guys right because there's
anti-heroes that do terrible things all
the time the punisher being an example
of that and so the fear of this is
enough to get this guy talking and he
basically dumps and says okay look you
know there's supposed to be like a great
big huge event going on right where
they're basically going to be showcasing
like all these weapons and things like
that and it's all going to be done kind
of underground as part of the uncle ben
foundation right like it's going to be
part of that event they're using it
using the uncle ben foundation as a guys
to showcase this stuff which is a pretty
crappy thing to do which again kind of
sends peter parker in a disarray because
for him it's just a personal offense
right disrespecting the memory of his
uncle ben now while that goes on you
have norman osborne with a fake face who
looks over at basically aunt may and
it's kind of like huh what are the
chances that i could have a face-to-face
conversation with someone she'd never
recognize me but let's go talk to her
right let's go kind of see what's going
on now behind the eyes of norman osborne
the wheels are turning and that if aunt
may is here of course he knows parker's
here because remember norman osborne
knows that peter parker is spider-man
more so than that depending on how
things go down he can use aunt may right
kidnapper something like that hold her
for ransom whatever the case happens to
be because he knows spider-man will do
anything to save the life of aunt may
the problem is that as he gets closer
suddenly you've got betty brandt who
refers to herself as betty betty lyman
suddenly you've got harry osborn who
says hey like my my last name's on
osborne anymore my last name is lyman
right harry lymon and that's when norman
realizes his son is there right not only
is his son his son's wife and his son's
kit right so he's kind of like wow okay
so uh after everything i handed you you
changed your name to your mother's last
name now here's the reason why this is
so important to norman osborne right and
it's one of the things we've probably
never really talked about over the
course of the various videos that we've
done about his character norman osborne
depending on how you look at it was
either a great father or a terrible
father he was a great father in so far
as he ensured that harry osborn never
wanted for anything he always had a
great education he always had whatever
he needed to succeed in the world he was
a bad father in the sense that he was
never there emotionally for his son he
was never really there in a supportive
capacity beyond simply just giving him
things and so because of that stuff it
created a kind of rift between harry and
norman and in fact harry osborne being
tired of being ignored by his father
switched the chemicals in an experiment
his father was conducting which is what
led to norman becoming the green goblin
in the first place so literally harry
turned his father into the green goblin
that kind of guilt went on for years
regarding harry once he learned the
green goblins to identity and in fact
it's one of the reasons why harry ended
up adopting the green goblin moniker
himself but the important thing here is
that the relationship between the two is
exceedingly tenuous but for the most
part norman looks at his son and says i
gave you everything right and this is
how you repay me by changing your last
name by casting aside your birthright
but at the end of the day while all
that's going on this invisible person is
yet again returned standing on a rooftop
and they were basically looking to do
the exact same thing that peter parker
and uh and mockingbird were doing which
was locate norman osborne and find a way
to take this guy out now granted this
person on the rooftop would do it with
violence right like executing the guy
from you know a block away spider-man
and mockingbird are not looking to kill
him they're looking to snatch him up and
then basically throw them in jail that's
really all they're really looking for
here or at least to find some way to tie
the criminal actions he's been engaged
in to norman himself and then use that
to throw him in jail and so ultimately
spider-man gets the upper hand on this
invisible person manages to take her out
and then uses his uh his sonic webbing
right his electrical uh web tech to
basically take out the stealth tech and
then we end up finding out that it's
silver sable now i know some of you guys
would be like silver stable really like
the most lackluster unmasking ever right
like the whole scooby-doo gang catches
up and they rip off the mask and they're
just like a random person right and it's
just you know i get that it might be a
little a little lackluster here but
here's the thing silver sable was
believed to have been dead uh and in
fact the the way the story arc with her
playing out was that she was supposedly
like died in the collapse of a building
you actually end up finding out that
somebody called the foreigner had
basically given her a android body to
kind of operate as her double out there
in the field so she is very much alive
um she's just kind of recovering from
all of her injuries so that's why her
android version is more or less here at
the moment the reason why she's here is
that she's an information broker right
that's what makes silver sables so
significant she's a person that brokers
information and can basically get you
anything you need to know on seemingly
anybody she's very similar to the heroes
for hire right misty knight colleen wing
shang chi those guys but she's just a
lot more capable and a lot of that's
because she's been around for much much
longer and she's been operating on a
much larger scale for much longer so
she's got contacts all over the world
right she knows pretty much everything
going on in the world at any particular
point in time because she can just get
that information from somebody and so
the ultimate thing behind this is that
in the midst of all this chaos when
spider-man attacks uh silver sable and
the gunshot goes off people start
fleeing for their lives norman osborne
appears to harry osborne but it really
just does it for the purpose of saying
like yes i'm alive right i'm alive and
i'm here right i mean obviously his face
is different but harry picks up on his
voice right and he's and it's really
just one of these things to say i'm very
much alive i'm not dead you just need to
know that son and then immediately takes
off to basically launch his weapons
presentation or at least his tech
presentation to all these different guys
now the crazy thing about this is that
of course this basically leads to an
alliance between silver sable and
mockingbird and spider-man the biggest
problem that you have here is what's
going on right now is in effect like a
giant
fight essentially spider-man is not a
person who has like political asylum
right like he's not supposed to be here
so launching an attack against anybody
in hong kong being an american citizen
shields immediately like we can't be
here right we cannot be a part of this
like shield is at the end of the day a
us government organization and so if
mockingbird is there who is a shield
agent alongside spider-man launching a
strike against somebody like uh like
norman osborn who most likely has found
a way to gain chinese citizenship even
if it's only under false pretenses then
what it looks like is the united states
government by way of shield and a
superhero are launching an attack
against a chinese citizen in hong kong
that is a
international rights disaster right it's
just it's the last thing anybody needs
stuff like this is how wars get started
and so immediately nick fury's like
bobby morris we can have nothing to do
with this back out right get out of here
and ultimately she ends up falling back
right because it's a direct order from
shield if she had said no to this and he
would have said fine right you're
disavowed he would have cut her off and
if anybody came asking any questions
like why was bobby morris a shield agent
in in hong kong with spider-man fighting
a chinese citizen regardless of whether
it's norman osborne or not the of shield
would be we told her not to and as soon
as she went with it anyway she would
stop becoming a shield agent do with her
whatever you want to right she's not our
problem anymore they would cut her off
right they would basically leave her out
to drive and so of course again this
kind of leads to this sort of alliance
whereas peter parker and silver sable
who continue on this path going across
and really attacking and trying to find
a way to capture norman osborne now
while that's happening that's when
norman osborne basically kicks off the
stream right now the stream was only
given to a select few people and it was
kind of a an access code or website on a
bit of a business card and so of course
harry osborne took one from one of the
crazy dictators that were out there and
so you have norman osborne kind of
putting on this show for everybody in
terms of here's what our technology is
able to do right spider-man and silver
stable chasing after him was designed to
lead them into a trap the whole point
was like literally he takes off he ends
up coming down and they like they follow
him right to where they're supposed to
be and when that goes down the whole
perception is that as far as they're
concerned that it was a demonstration of
like the goblin glider right the next
generation like the goblin glider so you
can fly around and it's got weapons and
different things like that right pumpkin
bombs and so on and it seems very just
kind of hackneyed right where it's just
one of these things where peter's like i
mean look man like this is this is this
is your weapons show right like goblin
gliders and pumpkin bombs and the
response of of norman is no no no that
was never what we were we were showing
like we're not we're not presenting
gliders things you could sit on and fly
that's not what we're showcasing here
and then you have the countess who steps
in and again we don't really know a
whole lot about her but we'll learn
about her here in a minute she steps in
and she says no no what we're here to
display is the king slayer mark one
literally this enormous mech suit you
end up having this really interesting
fight going on between like peter parker
silver sable like the king slayer mark
one and ultimately they're able to take
it out right like ultimately they're
able to destroy this thing using a
combination of parker technology you
know emp all that kind of stuff shock
you know shock tech and all that kind of
stuff what you would basically expect i
mean it literally happens over the
course of like two pages right and it's
literally like one page they're fighting
it the next page they've won like it's
it's not a great big huge long drawn out
uh battle between this thing but you end
up getting a bit of a background here
and what you end up learning and the
reason why silver stable is here is
because the countess is basically a
person who is uh operating out of a
place called simcaria and simcaria is a
nation where of course as most people
who are familiar with silver sable know
that that's where she comes from what
the countess had done was allied herself
with norman osborne and then basically
subjugate the population and turn the
entire country of cimcaria into what is
in effect a weapons manufacturing plant
right literally everybody there just
build weapo builds weapons that's all
they do and the purpose comes two-fold
one is so norman osborn can build up his
presence in the criminal underworld
scene because as we know the biggest
motivation of norman osborn over the
course of his life prior to becoming the
green goblin was to rule the criminal
underworld after becoming the green
goblin it was killing spider-man and
then ruling the criminal underworld and
so kind of regaining his bearing sort of
going back to basics in that way it was
basically norman osborne working
alongside the countess to build up all
these weapons and then sell them off to
the highest bidders to make himself kind
of the guy that people go to whenever
they need a way to fight off some kind
of uh enemy force or to conquer our
country or to maintain their control
over a country the second thing that's
going on here is that norman osborne is
basically creating an entire goblin army
in simcaria right like literally flying
these fumes over the whole city and
creating an enormous goblin army and so
the response and really what kind of
goes on here is you basically have harry
osborn you've got aunt may who's brought
in by uh by shield right you've
literally got like bobby morris who's
talking to nick fury and it's kind of
like look i get that we're not
necessarily supposed to be there but you
guys have to understand what norman
osborne is doing out here is one a
violation of human rights so who knows
how many uh human rights laws he's
broken and two he's gonna become a
massive credible threat to shield itself
and so ultimately bobby morris ends up
going on this mission now the problem
with this is that it's not sanctioned
nick fury's still not behind this he's
like no like we're not getting involved
there and so quite literally bobby
morris basically forms her own kind of
small band team right which is pretty
cool right i mean they basically call it
the wild pack but nonetheless the thing
about this is she's like i resigned from
shield she's like this is something
that's more important right i can't just
idly sit by and let this happen more so
than that bonnie morris is growing to
care about peter parker right she dare i
say she kind of loves him right she
believes in it right and it's one of
those things where literally
spider-man's talking to her and he's
like thanks for doing this i owe you one
and she's like well i've worked with you
long enough to know whatever you're
doing here you're doing it for the right
reasons and he's like oh you believe in
me you know she's like okay now you're
making it weird but obviously there's a
kind of of romance blending between the
two right obviously there's a there's
feelings developing there and so
launching and you know kind of making
their move into some karya one of the
other things that's happened too is that
norman osborne has kind of gotten back
his original face the big problem with
this is that he's all kind of grotesque
looking and the reason why as it's
explained to the doctor who he
ultimately turns into one of his goblin
members because he doesn't have a use
for him anymore is that the human face
can only go through so many surgeries in
such a short amount of time and the
muscles don't quite have chance to have
a chance to recover so in effect norman
osborne has screwed up the muscles in
his face and that's why his face looks
all screwed up and so because of that
he's kind of grotesque and and twisted
and when spider-man silver sable
mockingbird when wild pack when they all
get into cycaria they end up going
against these king slayer mark ones as
well as the entire goblin army which is
kind of nuts now a combination of spider
tech silver sable basically getting back
here and actually kind of returning to
being a champion of the people and
freeing her people from the the clutches
of the countess it all sort of comes
together and it sees them literally just
crushing this goblin army now the big
difference here between the goblin army
as it previously existed and the goblin
army as he exists now is that in years
past again when the goblin army
initially showed up it was people in
suits right it was people who were
dressed up people who were designed to
look like goblins what osborne's done
here is he's physically changed the
appearance of people to look like
goblins like quite literally change
their physiology to turn them into
actual goblins and that's what sort of
sends peter parker up the wall because
he's like my god like you literally
screwed these people up like what have
you done and that's when osborne kind of
reveals that the goblin serum was always
his greatest invention and then what he
intends to do is quite literally put
this goblin serum in a nuke fire it into
the atmosphere and then basically create
a world of goblins right like his own
personal goblin army which of course as
we know can't stand for that
and so once this happens right with a
with a nuke basically being launched
into the air right a missile flying out
there somewhere it's all hands on deck
right so this really becomes kind of the
crisis moment here so it really kind of
boils down to a combination of silver
sable facing off against the countess
right too uh to basically be the one to
rule simcaria which this has whatever
symbology and whatever meaning you
really want to assign to it it's not
really all that important the real meat
and potatoes of this comes down with
peter parker facing off against norman
osborne now that's one of the things to
keep in mind is that historically
speaking when it came to the goblin
formula under superior spider-man that
the way it was done norman osborne
cannot become the green goblin anymore
the goblin serum doesn't work on it
anymore and that's exactly what happens
here the reed tries to inject himself
with his newest strain of the goblin
formula it doesn't work right nothing
works that he basically can't defeat
peter parker the way that he
traditionally would more so than that
the kind of gas that he emits around
spider-man basically robs him of his of
his spider sense the other part of that
is that he intends to kind of boil this
down to really more of a one-on-one
fight right that by robbing spider-man
of his fighter sense and then in turn uh
using what is essentially a kind of emp
to rob him of any of the tech built into
his suit that is just a knock down drag
out fight between two guys it's even in
the playing field and this is a pretty a
pretty significant moment here because
the truth is and while this really could
have been more of like a big event i'm
kind of glad that it was confined down
to just being a singular story involving
norman osborne that this is basically
peter parker facing off against norman
as they are right there's no web
shooters no none of that stuff right
it's simply just peter parker the guy
where his powers are seemingly gone and
then norman osborne is just a guy right
so they are 100 on an even keel here for
peter parker it's personal right norman
osborne is synonymous with the death of
gwen stacy and so in a lot of ways
defeating him like finally taking him
out is a way to kind of avenge uh gwen
stacy yourself and so the fight like
literally leads out into the snow on the
side of a mountain i mean this is just a
hardcore fight between these guys now
the big problem here is that again while
all this is going on the missile is
firing right the missiles are flying
right i mean they're just they're just
out there and norman osborne is getting
the upper hand on peter parker now
that's one of the funny things about
this and it's one of the things that dan
sloth kind of plays with and it's one of
the things that not every spider-man fan
was receptive to right what this does is
put forward this idea that without his
proportional strength of a spider
without his web shooters and his
enhanced agility peter parker's useless
there's nothing he can do right he's he
has no real skills whatsoever this flies
in the face of the fact that peter
parker learned his martial art the way
of the spider right like he literally
learned a martial art style taught to
him by shang chi and that norman osborne
doesn't really have a particular martial
art right he's not really fighting using
kung fu or or brazilian jiu-jitsu it's
not like he was trained at the hands of
the gracies but it's just one of these
things where he's just a guy and him and
peter parker involved in a bare knuckle
fight a lot of spider-man fans looked at
this and said no this fight never should
have happened this way right it should
have been peter parker just overpowering
this guy even if he only had just you
know standard strength of like of of an
adult he has a martial art style he
should know how to overcome counter this
guy's moves now in the midst of all this
essentially the missile suddenly stops
right the missile is basically caught by
what was you know the friends of
spider-man right mockingbird and those
guys basically bring it to a halt you
know they end up catching it right so it
essentially gets deactivated and the
formula never gets spread and that
momentary distraction peter parker gets
the upper hand on on norman osborne and
again the fight jonah kind of continues
on that's one of the things that i liked
about this it wasn't really one of those
small little kind of like was a
momentary distraction and then it's like
one punch done right and then he's like
let's get back to the fray it's not like
that right it's a momentary distraction
gives peter parker the upper hand and
then they're right back into it again
now in the midst of all that then it's
also like the arrival of shield right
now when that happens when peter
parker's distracted norman osborne bails
right he takes that moment and just gets
out as fast as he possibly can right he
just runs because he knows that if he
stays here and he fights spider-man that
the fight is going to go on long enough
to where neither one of them is really
going to win shields forces are going to
show up they're going to snatch up
norman and norman's going to be taken to
jail the smartest thing for him to do is
bail out the other part of this is nick
fury's like look i applaud yurah's
desire to do the right thing but let's
be honest here right by coming into
somkaria which was rightfully ruled by
the countess and having norman osborne
as her aid by defeating her you've
basically toppled a government and
shield could not be a part of this right
it will not be said that shield helps
spider-man topple a lawfully run
government right a lawfully recognized
government no we're not helping you
overthrow foreign powers
so he's like shield wants nothing to do
with this he's like so from from here on
out shield has nothing to do with you
spider-man we are completely and totally
severing ties with uh with parker
industries right you guys are cut off we
are no longer in bed with each other
which is kind of a smart move to be
honest with you guys but parker
industries comes in of course provides
resources different things like that to
help these guys out but the other
follow-up to this and what really kind
of comes out of this and really leads
into the return of the green goblin is
norman osborne reflects back on his
fight with peter parker all these
various schemes that he's been involved
in and comes to this realization that
the only time he ever came close to
defeating and even killing spider-man is
when he was the green goblin and so in
his mind he has to find some way to get
the goblin formula back the funny thing
about this is norman's gonna go to some
pretty desperate measures to make that
happen the problem is once it does
happen probably becomes deadlier really
worse than he ever was right just this
really twisted and sadistic version of
his character probably leading into one
of the greatest stories that marvel's
ever written involving the green goblin
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace